now do you notice like uh yeah you said
there's like fans like whenever you have
fans from a long time ago that had been
with you since the beginning kind of
it is interesting because you kind of
listen to them and sometimes i'll almost
go to them for like a point of view of
myself that i
feel like i can't get anymore yeah now i
get that dude i
you know there's some people it's been
so long since we've played shows so i
haven't seen their faces in a long time
but
i mean there was this one guy in like
the south carolina north carolina
anywhere in that region he would come to
just
every single show you know and i'd
always talk to him maybe have a drink
with him or whatever he was just like my
boy
yeah and then there was this lady and
her and her family member
they came to i don't know like
20-something shows like you know in a
year or something something insane you
know yeah
and those you know you start seeing
those faces and you start i don't know
you start
really appreciating them and start
caring for them and i and yeah you know
if i look for a comment i might look for
theirs first and be like yeah
you know they they get it you know yeah
yeah there is something special about
that yeah like i used to have a couple
of people that would drive to different
shows like come
one guy drove his like he had this like
beautiful car he'd refurbished and he
brought it up from
like tallahassee and drove it up so i
could see it at a show one time
you know just because we had an
interaction online and it was just like
man it's pretty
it was just interesting you know but
then i felt next thing i'm riding around
the block in his car and stuff
like that you know it's interesting the
fans you kind of have from the beginning
you know it is i mean
at that point you don't really think
about it you're like you know you may be
like oh well they're here again you know
great but the the longer the longer you
get going and the more people that jump
on the wagon you kind of i don't know
you just never forget them i guess you
never probably will
and that's that's kind of cool yeah
super cool but you can't like it's
interesting because in the beginning you
can kind of have a beer with that one
guy or you can kind of have a beer with
that you know the mom and daughter that
came and you can give them a hug after a
show and
there's you know you can hang out
outside of the venue and spend a little
bit of time with you
but then that starts to go away
definitely um
and yeah i mean for you you can't i mean
you can't do that anymore no no
you can't and like i said it's been so
long since i've since i've even played a
show
i feel like things have even for for us
the last since the last time we played a
show and now
uh things have grown so exponentially i
mean it's like unreal how much they've
grown
so i don't even i'm not even sure what i
can what i couldn't can't do it in
inside in a
in a venue you know because it's just
it's just so much different but yeah i
remember we used to play some
you know we we started playing shows me
and my booking agent
we we had a you know whole plan you know
instead of going and opening for other
people
playing you know clubs and theaters and
opening for someone
let's just go do our own thing in these
tiny places and build it from the ground
up amen
so like we would go to like i can't
remember like the boat house in myrtle
beach or something else called something
like that you know and
i would i would play i'd play a show for
maybe a hundred people 200 people
probably 100 boats
no no they're why i don't even think it
was hot i don't even think it's on the
water
but i can't remember what i don't know
if that's the exact name that i could be
wrong
that's like a oyster bar but they only
have lamb yeah it's like oh man
um but that would bring i would bring
people up on the bus
and that's like that's when i first got
a bus you know it's like i was i
probably i wasn't making any money
i was losing money to pay for this buck
yeah if you if you have a bus in the
beginning
you're losing money oh yeah i was losing
money for sure
and uh but i would bring them up there
and i'd play songs like four or five
people i'd play them songs on my bus you
know just on the guitar and they would
hang and it was like
i think those are moments that i you
know i didn't realize how how
unique those moments were at the time
because i didn't i didn't know if i was
going to do any more than that i didn't
know if i was going to make it any
further i didn't know if i was going to
get another bus i didn't know if i was
going to get a tractor trailer you know
i didn't
i thought i might have to give this one
buzz back real quick
so uh but it's looking back now it's
those moments were really unique and
special and
and i know i'll i'll remember them and i
think they will too yeah
yeah it's funny man it's interesting how
like um yeah those moments it's like
they just kind of disappear it's they
don't disappear i mean you always have
them but
you can't go back and relive that exact
same thing a little bit
no you can't and i think that's part of
what makes them unique and special you
know because if you could continue to do
them then it would just not be a special
for for anyone it would just be a known
thing and i think that's part of
you know the the the mystique about
something like that
um but yeah it would it it's it's
it's funny to think about like the the
steps that you take to to get where
you're going and how beautiful a lot of
those
you know those things those moments that
you yeah once you look back you realize
how unique and special they were you
know and you don't
once you get to a massive scale it's
kind of just like a lot of them are the
same
kind of deals the whole way through you
know it's like oh you've reached this
point where do you where do you go now
right yeah you start working with the
same company everybody's kind of it
becomes a little bit more like a best
buy kind of
more corporate a little more corporate
good evening good afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you can watch
could be way better what if you watch a
video right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one
watch this one watch this one watch this
one
ah